Okay. The real answer is none of these. For 2 to the 4th, I know that's 2 times
2 times 2 times 2. I have repeated multiplication 4 times, so I get 16. That's
definitely not 18. For 3 to the 6th, I have 3 times 3 times 3 times 3 times 3
times 3, which is really 9 times 9 times 9, or 729.
That's definitely not 18. 6 to the 3rd is 6 times 6 times 6. So, I get 216.
Here, I just have 9 squared. So, 9 times 9. I have the repeated multiplication
of 9. Well, that makes 81. 81 isn't 18 even though they both have digits of 8
and 1. For this last one, I just have 1 18 times. That's a lot a 1's. But I know
1 times 1 times 1 times 1 is always just going to be 1. So, this answer is going
to equal 1. So, that's not it either. This is why it's important to think about
what an exponent means. Most of the math you do on a daily basis involves
multiplication. That's why it's so easy to think of exponents as multiplication.
We have to slow down and remind ourselves that 2 to the 4th isn't really 8, it's
really 16. Just like 9 squared is really 81.